last question today is from Alana who
says how can you distinguish creativity
and insanity I don't know the answer I
mean we we have a picture of Vincent van
Gogh up who was known for both being a
creative genius and somebody who had
significant mental challenges uh so I
don't know the answer I mean we have a
conversation often when it comes to
religion where we say if someone says
there's a man in the sky talking to me
uh we would say well you should go be
seen by a psychiatrist and other times
you would say well you're you're
Christian or you're Muslim or you're
Jewish or that's a religion I don't know
the way Pat I mean is there a specific
test you can give someone to say you're
a creative genius or you are someone who
is mentally challenged or insane to use
a colloquial term Society has
established parameters that in many ways
are arbitrary much of what is accepted
as reasonable religious beliefs are what
in other circumstances would be
considered a mental illness yeah I mean
there's no way to tell either way you
could be both very easily yeah I mean I
can't think of a test if if you said to
someone very specifically do you believe
XYZ and you made them beliefs that are
sort of sometimes interpreted to be what
we would call insane beliefs and
sometimes to be the the beliefs of
devout believers how do you say well
depending on the vocabulary we say this
person's crazy in that person's just
they have faith III don't really get it
and I know that this is a really tough
conversation particularly for many
believers to have because even they
recognize that if someone just says I'm
hearing voices and they're telling me to
do bad things they would say you've got
to get checked out maybe psychiatric
medication is in order but if they go to
a church and say God told me to do XY
and Z and it's a good thing we said
that's a that's a great person that's it
that's a believer I don't know it seems
like a bit of a double standard to me
yes it's not really considered crazy if
everyone else believes it too if you
have a church full of people twenty
thousand in a mega church who say Jesus
is against abortion and we should be
against abortion hey that's a shared
belief and it's not considered crazy if
one person says God told me I should
kill anyone who steals from a
convenience store all of a sudden we say
wait a second did God really tell you
that that's maybe a belief we should
examine further uh interesting question
I wish I had a better answer and I want
to open it to the audience on this one
if you have a very specific answer as to
how to distinguish creativity and and
insanity send me an email and maybe
we'll follow up on it on the bonus show
which is next if you remember by the way